[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la côte d'ivoire peut-elle devenir une
grande nation sportive d'ici à 15 ans
c'est la question qui nous est posée ce
soir est ce que la côte d'ivoire peut
rentrer dans top 10 des grandes nations
sportives vers 2030
alors pour étayer ma démonstration je
m'appuyais sur deux sports qui sont dans
vos mémoires collectives
il s'agit du taekwondo et l'ascétisme en
ce qui concerne l'accès actis me lave a
commencé à à une année zéro pomas et
l'année 2013 en 2013 il ya un an avant
il ya un après parce qu'en 2013 muriel
amour et remporte non elle médaille
d'argent en fait qu'elle va remporter
aux championnats du monde d'athlétisme
sur le 100 m et 100 m 200 m le rêve va
se poursuivre aux jeux olympiques parce
qu'on attend beaucoup du potentiel des
coureurs ivoiriens il ya un certain
youssef benitez qui va rentrer dans le
stade olympique
et c'est un moment très particulier
parce que vous savez le 100 m aux jeux
olympiques c'est quelque chose
d'incroyable
au 100 m c'est la moitié de la planète
qui s'arrêtent ya ce truc qui est
hallucinant où pendant 10 secondes la
moitié de la planète s'arrêtent pour
regarder les forts en train de rebondir
et c'est youssef ben humanité qui va
entrer le premier dans le stade
olympique
bien avant un certain usain bolt et la
honda très fiers les ivoiriens ensuite
il ya une petite merveille cette
merveille
petite déception parce qu'elle arrive et
4e au 100 m avec un 1000e de retard sur
la troisième
elle ne sera pas sur ce podium vous
savez ce que ça fait 1 milliard sur un
100 m ça représente un cheveu c'est la
taille d'un cheveu qui lui a manqué pour
remporter la médaille de bronze
cette jeune fille c'est marie josée
times elles arrivent également
quatrième sur le 200 m aux jeux
olympiques doriot il ne sera pas sur le
podium n'emportera pas de médaille
heureusement il ya eu cette année cette
année 2010 est nous avons les
championnats du monde qui se sont
déroulés à londres dans ce stade magie
mythique où j'ai assisté d'ailleurs à
quelques performances en 2012 et la
marie josée elle va nous combler parce
qu'il y a ce 100 m où elle va remporter
la médaille d'argent
il va réitérer l'exploit d'une certaine
muriel ah ouais c'est à dire qu'elle va
remporter la médaille d'argent également
sur le 200 m alors on peut se demander
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour que les
ivoiriens performe esprits déjà
peut-être pas ce qu'est une école du
sprint mais j'ai une autre explication
en fait les ivoiriens comme dans
d'autres sports ont performé en sprint
parce qu'ils se sont débarrassés d'un
complexe d'infériorité
ce complexe d'infériorité qui faisait
que certains africains baveux un
complexe vis-à-vis de l'europe vis-à-vis
de l'occident vis-à-vis du reste du
monde et il était assez inhibé pour ne
pas se livrer complètement et totalement
vous aurez peut-être du mal à le croire
alors ce que je vous propose maintenant
c'est de le vérifier avec une grande
championne elle n'est pas venue avec ses
médailles d'argent mais elle est là avec
nous je demandais à mari jaloux de nous
rejoindre korité vous l'avez connu un
moment et si vous l'avez connu à quel
moment justement vous vous remettez
débarrasser oui je me rappelle que dans
mes débuts c'était quand même difficile
et que je voyais toutes ces personnes là
qui étaient les jamaïcaines et
américaines qui est au sommet et moi je
me disais mais à quel moment j'allais
arriver à ce niveau là et je me rappelle
qu'en 2015
je disais à mon coach quand est ce que
j'avais fait la diamond league pour la
première fois et il m'a dit bon
peut-être un jour et ça n'a pas duré je
pense deux semaines après man
mon manager m'a finalement tu apprécies
la diamond league de paris et tuba
compéti j'y aille mais si cette diamond
league là quelles sont les différentes
personnes qui se rend la médaille
laitiers à petit comme ça j'ai pas les
cours y avait cette villa est
franchement dit je veux pas j'ai peur et
l image jeune fille comme elle n'en a
dit oui mais moi j'ai pas encore atteint
ce niveau et je suis arrivé je me
rappelle que ces blessés pour cabaret
qui moi me disait pas la même au niveau
que ses filles tu peux quand même
quelque chose du bien et je me rappelle
que ce jeu là ya du beau jeu et je vois
que l un départ canon donc si j'ai un
bon départ je pense que je peux arriver
les premiers donc se joue là je me
rappelle que j'avais quand même
elle n'est pas explosif et j'étais
devant j'ai couru couru jusqu'à j'ai vu
j'étais milices sixième je pense et je
fais mon meilleur record c'était 11 06 a
dit que si c'est la volonté j'ai plus un
je suis arrivé c'était mon coach quoi tu
penses c'est bon maintenant je sais que
ces filles là je peux les battre
il suffit juste que je m'entraîne
vraiment bien et ça va aller il c'est
comme ça à partir de ce moment-là que
j'ai plus peur d'être inquiète c'est ça
qui est extraordinaire c'est que nous
avons une génération d'athlètes une
génération aussi de chef d'entreprise
j'ai pu le voir ce matin avec les
différentes conférences auxquelles on a
assisté qui n'ont plus ce sentiment
d'infériorité qui prévalait notamment
chez nos parents parce qu'il est vrai
que il fut un temps les américaines
semblaient imbattables jamaïcaine
semblait imbattable on perdait déjà
quelques millièmes dixièmes de seconde
rien qu'en voyant ces athlètes entrée
sur la piste mais elle a été beaucoup
plus loin marie-josée parce qu'il aurait
pu faire comme certains ou certaines de
ses collègues s'exiler quitté le
continent africain pour s'entraîner en
se disant que peut-être les meilleurs
entraîneurs sont en europe et aux états
unis
non
restez sur le continent africain est
resté sur le continent africain et elle
s'est entraînée où ça à dakar au centre
d'entraînement de dakar pourquoi ce
choix
faux dit que au début je pensais que ce
entraînement en europe donner les moyens
d'arriver au même niveau des défis et
quand je revenais en 2013 de la chine
j'ai eu la possibilité pour la chance
d'aller à dakar c'est une chance parce
que c'était pas évident que je sois
apprise au centre de la page et essuie
liste d'attenté bon dieu faisant je suis
arrivé à dacca et j'ai eu la possibilité
de tomber c'est un bon coach gagnera
rien et qui m'a prise comme sa fille et
qui a su c'est qu'il me manquait et je
sais que à dacca s'entraînait à monter
les mondiaux qui a été la championne du
monde du 400 m et qui est entraînée par
un putsch et je me dis juste du bon ok
on va tenter une année et on verra au
fur et à mesure que je m'entraînais je
voyais que j'ai avancé et que c'est que
j'aimerais pas fait quand j'étais en
chine
je les fais ipad à temps et je pense je
demande à mon coach mes coaches moi je
comprends pas on a data on arrive à fait
ce que les autres qui sont des trois
pouvoirs
c'est quoi le secret et dia pas vraiment
de secret déjà faut savoir que ici en
afrique on a tous on à la plage et le
soleil
il ya tout au fait ya la bonne
nourriture et tout et que si tu te rends
compte ceux qui sont en europe pendant
l'hiver il cherche des pays où il fait
chaud vous voit s'entraîner parce que
c'est pas évident pour un sprinteur de
pouvoir faire sa préparation physique
dans le fond je me suis dit bon déjà il
ya ça mais je pense qu'il ya aussi la
volonté de la personne de pouvoir
montrer peut-être à ceux qui sont là-bas
que étant ici en afrique on peut être
comme eux et je pense qu'il n'est jamais
qu'un ils sont vraiment bons ils sont 1
mais aussi en amérique mais elle
s'entraîne chez eux de façon aussi dur
comme nous les africains on s'entraîne
et j'arrive à fait ces résultats là et
j'ai dit au coach bon je pense que moi
après 1,1 montrent les machos je serai
la seule africaine qui s'entraîne en
afrique et qui arrive à fait ce que les
âmes
week-end ce que les jamaïquaines fond et
je pense qu'avec ce que je vais produits
comme travail
les faits qui sont derrière qui pensent
que c'est forcément aller s'entraîner en
europe qu'un verrons ça elles seront que
ici on a pratiquement pouvoir évoluer
avancé et je sais que ça sera pas facile
ça sera dur parce qu'il y aura pas
vraiment les moyens
on va pas vraiment les instituts mais je
pense que avec nos petits moyens qu'on a
avec la volonté que j'ai avec vous aussi
ce que vous savez de ce sport là on va
se donner les moyens d'avancer et je
pense que le résultat lui même va parler
de lui est différent sorte que ces
personnes là voudront venir s'entraîner
en afrique et je pense que cette année
par mes résultats ça a payé
parce que tout le monde pensait que je
m'entraînais offert aux états unis ou en
france
ils étaient étonnés de savoir que
j'étais à dakar et avec un pote il voit
rien qui est africain
ils sont dix bas si vous faites ça la
mosson bovine s'entraîne avec vous donc
je pense que j'ai quand même j'ai quand
même on peut pas réussi mon pari à 100%
on va dire assez con pour cent parce que
lyon quoi des choses qui vont se fait
derrière parce que là maintenant je vais
valoriser les troupes de mon pays je
vais m'entraîner ici et amener ces
jeunes là qui sont derrière qui n'ont
pas la possibilité de bach à cet
entraînement là de pouvoir exceller
comme moi aussi j'ai excellé à voir même
s'ils n'ont pas de moyens mais je pense
qu'avec la motivation que je vais les
aborder avec ce que mon coach fera et
les autres je pense qu'ils auront cette
envie-là d'aller titiller déjà ceux qui
sont là bas on a commencé avec 6 gatti
que vous connaissez qui s'entraîne avec
nous et ça paye
et il y en a beaucoup qui viennent
derrière et j'espère que d'autres pays
africains
on se fixe pas et ouvre et comme nous
aurons des pelles en afrique et je vais
vous raconter une petite histoire qui
directement lié à ce qu'a vécu
marie-josée cet été c'était notamment
lors de la finale du 200 mètres a été
remportée par le néerlandais skipper
j'étais avec un animateur vedette de
chez vous yves de mbella ici à abidjan
ont dîné dans un bon restaurant de
abidjan pour assister à sa course
elle est arrivée deuxième avec skipper
seine et marnaise qui
danser tout autour du stade pour fêter
sa victoire il était malheureux pour
elle
yves de mbella qu'est ce qu'il a fait je
vous garantis il a pleuré
il a pleuré de tristesse parce qu'elle
n'avait pas remporté la médaille d'or
alors maintenant je vais demander à
marie josée et bien à tokyo de remporter
une médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques
s'il te plaît on laisse pas en afrique
avec un entraîneur ivoirien
et là je vais bien ma compagne est il de
mbella il pleurait avec lui parce que
c'est possible ça sera possible avec le
soutien de tout le monde les prier et
puis bon si tu avais un message à donner
à tous les jeunes vivent rien qui nous
écoute parce qu'on a parlé de ce
sentiment d'infériorité
il faut le balayer tu ne crains pas les
américaines et jamaïcaines qu'est ce
qu'il doit faire dans la vie justement
pour ce sentiment disparaissent
il faut que déjà et commence à avoir
confiance en eux mêmes parce que moi je
sais que c'est parce que au début
j'avais pas confiance je ne pensais pas
que je pouvais arriver au même niveau
que ses fils a donc déjà commencé à
avoir confiance en eux
persévérez surtout parce que arrivée
moment je pense que ça sera du mois il
ya des moments où je me suis enfermé
dans ma chambre j'ai pleuré parce que je
me suis dit que franchement dit j'avance
mais je vois pas le résultat au fait
donc après c'est surtout persévérer
courant ses rêves et puis se donner les
moyens de les réaliser
moi j'ai pas eu tous les moyens
nécessaires pour pouvoir avancer des
médailles d'argent là j'ai pas eu les
moyens je sais comment j'ai galéré avec
le coach mais je me suis pas dit que bon
voilà comme j'ai pas les moyens
j'abandonne je vais chercher quelque
chose de facile vous fait non j'avais
fois j'apprends ce que je faisais
j'avais confiance que j'avais la
capacité le moyen d'arriver à cela
donc j'ai fait mais je suis beaucoup de
choses j'ai fait mais je suis beaucoup
de choses et je me suis donné les moyens
d'y arriver
donc la facilité de prix marie un set a
dit ça ça va rien apporter au contraire
devant ça serait encore ça sera pas
meilleur en tout cas même si déjà on
commence comme on dit au bout de
l'effort que se trouve le réconfort
donc on se donne les moyens d'arriver at
il donné moyen d'avancer
et je pense qu'il n'y a pas moyen que si
tu te donne vraiment assez à ce que tu
ce que tu tu sais pouvoir le faire n'a
pas moins que le puisse parer à arriver
au fait donc se donner les moyens la
capacité ensuite à aussi de beaucoup
prier dieu parce que je pense qu'il ya
ça comme on dit aide toi le ciel
t'aidera
ce titre de 30 à 60 70 % girafe à lui
reste donc ça viendra double champion
vice championne du monde de sprint
l'athlétisme est également le taekwondo
le taekwondo qui est très importante
pour vous la côte d'ivoire avec
notamment jacques si c'est un rude dhabi
qui ont remporté respectivement la
médaille d'or et la médaille d'argent
aux derniers jeux olympiques de rio est
en fait la réussite de ces athlètes nous
a démontré la montée en puissance des
sportifs ivoiriens dans ce sport
originaire de corée mais il faut élargir
en fait cette réussite à l'afrique noire
il ya l'afrique de l'ouest et même à
l'afrique centrale puisque incertain il
souffrait le tag a remporté en taekwondo
la médaille d'argent dans la catégorie
des lourds et si on revient à l'ombre
2012 un certain on peut venir obama en
2012 avait gagné médaille d'argent
également dans la catégorie des lourds
alors et des performances et ses
performances on peut les attribuer
notamment l'engouement pour les sports
de combat au près d'un grand public
mise à part les scream année ce crime
qui est un peu à part en afrique en
raison du coût est également de la
complexité de son installation la
complexité de la technicité alors en
taekwondo quand en 2012 la fédération
internationale a décidé d'imposer un
matériel électronique pour la pratique
de ce sport
on aurait pu penser que les athlètes
africains allait être diminué à l'être
empêcher il en a strictement rien été
bien au contraire des équipes nationales
qui s'entraîner ici ont pu performer
je parle du niger je parle du gabon je
parle également de la côte d'ivoire
alors comment expliquer ce résultat
ça on le doit notamment à quatre
facteurs très importants
le premier facteur c'est la fédération
internationale qu'il faut remercier
parce qu'elle a décidé d'organiser sur
le continent africain
les compétitions de
les plans des compétitions mondiales de
tout premier plan
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu vous somme
continent africain un championnat du
monde de cyclisme
non un championnat du monde de volley
non une coupe du monde non en revanche
on a eu ici à abidjan en 2013
une coupe du monde de taekwondo par
équipes 2014
c est une coupe du monde francophone à
dakar et il ya les open et open ce sont
ces grands tournois de référence de ont
été organisées à louxor en egypte en
2015 2016 qui a permis aux athlètes
d'afrique noire de pouvoir se rendre
dans ces tournois de référence
ensuite il ya quelque chose
d'extraordinaire il on doit remercier la
fédération continentale
la confédération africaine de taekwondo
qui a fait quelque chose vraiment très
chouette
elle a décidé d'appliquer un principe de
solidarité
je vous parle moi de l'appareillage
électroniques utilisés aux jeux
olympiques qui coûte très cher et bien
elle la distribuer à chaque région à
chaque pays pour qu'ils puissent
compétitif comme aux jeux olympiques que
dans les championnats du monde ce qui
fait que les athlètes ont tout de suite
était au niveau des meilleurs après il
ya la fédération est également les
gouvernements qui ont décidé d'installer
une politique de haut niveau pérenne et
enfin il ya la structuration de
l'encadrement qui étaient d'un niveau
professionnel
ce qui a permis par exemple à certains
athlètes comme cheikh cissé ou le
gabonais obame pour les jeux olympiques
de 2016
quant à eux de pouvoir se qualifier
directement pour l'olympiade sans passer
par les qualifications au nez et à la
barbe des pays occidentaux
je vous parle de quoi là je vous parle
tout simplement de la faculté que des
africains se sont donnés en grandissant
chez eux en se formant chez eux et en
considérant qu'ils avaient tous les
atouts ici pour devenir les meilleurs au
monde et je pense raisonnablement
qu'avec le potentiel de la côte d'ivoire
ce pays peut devenir un grand pays de
sport il faudrait rajouter quelque chose
d'extrêmement important
et là je m'adresse aux acteurs publics
de ce pays
il faut absolument garantir la paix
qu'il y ait la paix une certaine
tranquillité pour que le sportif puck
s'exprimer et que vous puissiez remporté
les médailles
[Applaudissements]